und ich rufe nun auf den Zusatzpunkt
Nummer 6 die erste Beratung des von den
Fraktionen spd-bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Zahlung einer einmaligen
energiepauschale für Studierende
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler sowie
berufsfach Schülerinnen und
Berufsfachschüler in Bildungsgängen mit
dem Ziel eines mindestens zweijährigen
berufsqualifizierenden Abschlusses 200 €
sollen Studierende sowie Fachschüler und
Fachschülerinnen bekommen als
Energiepreis pauschale da ist vieles
noch nicht abschließend geklärt die
Pauschale muss beantragt werden von
denen die sie beantragen dürfen wann
genau sie bezahlt werden soll ist im
Moment noch gar nicht konkret genannt
die Länder sollen zunächst den
Vorausleistung treten und der Bund so
ist es geplant soll den Ländern dann die
ausgegebenen Mittel erstatten das ganze
soll dann bis Ende des Jahres 23
passieren
anspruchsberechtigt sind fast 3 million
Studierende und etwa 450.000
Fachschülerinnen Fachschüler hier in
Deutschland
auch noch mehr dazu kriegen Sie jetzt
von der zuständigen Ministerin Bettina
steigt Watzinger
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das heißt ja
immer Jugend ist schön unbeschwert doch
in diesen Tagen die jungen Menschen
haben in der corona-pandemie auf viel
verzichten müssen jetzt der Krieg mit
seinen Folgen nein früher war nicht
alles besser aber wer in diesem Zeiten
seine Jugend erlebt er hat es nicht so
leicht
umso wichtiger dass wir auch immer die
junge Generation mitdenken beim
Bewältigen der Krise dass wir Sie nicht
alleine lassen dazu ist der
Gesetzentwurf da
die
energiepreispauschale ist dafür
Studierende für Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler 200 Euro die steigende
kostenabfedern 200 Euro die das Leben
ein Stück leichter machen 200 Euro die
ein Stück mehr Freiheit bringen
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler sie
sollen sich auf ihre Ausbildung
konzentrieren mehr konzentrieren als auf
die Heizkosten Studierende sich lieber
über die Hausarbeit den Kopf zerbrechen
als über ihre Stromrechnung das ist mein
Ziel als Bundesbildungsministerin was
was sieht der Gesetzentwurf konkret vor
Anspruch haben alle die immatrikuliert
sind an einer Hochschule in Deutschland
stichtag ist der erste Dezember das gilt
auch für Studierende aus anderen Ländern
die in Deutschland leben
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler sind
ebenfalls berechtigt auch
berufsfachschülerinnen und Schüler die
einen mindestens zweijährigen
Bildungsgang absolvieren mit
berufsqualifizierenden Abschluss
insgesamt sind das fast 3,5 Millionen
junge Menschen in allen Bundesländern an
zahlreichen Hochschulen und
Ausbildungsstätten sie können einen
Antrag stellen und das Geld erhalten das
hat es in dieser Dimension noch nicht
gegeben
und um die Dimension auch mal klar zu
machen weil es wird ja oft mit der KfW
und den auszahlungswegen verglichen
damals waren es
18181.000 Antragsteller die reden hier
über 3,5 Millionen Anträge in kurzer
Zeit und deswegen haben wir auch keine
Blaupause ja klar man wünscht sich Knopf
drücken und das Geld ist auf den Kunden
weil ich ja gleich weiß was von der
Opposition kommt sie haben die
Regierungsbank verlassen und haben eine
hypothekenhypothek hinterlassen ich
suche heute noch die von Minister
Altmaier versprochene digitale
bürgerfreundlichste Verwaltung Europas
Fehlanzeige Digitalisierung haben wir in
riesigen aufholbedarfen eine Damen und
Herren so wir haben viele Hochschulen
viele Fachschulen aber es gibt kein
bundesweites Verzeichnis mit den
notwendigen Daten und deswegen hören Sie
doch mal zu damit die jungen Menschen
wissen was auf sie zukommt es wird eine
Online-Plattform geben wo man das Geld
beantragen kann und wir arbeiten mit
Hochdruck dran Länder sind eingebunden
denn ohne sie geht es nicht und alle
haben ein Ziel dass es möglich wird
Sachsen-Anhalt steht bereit besondere
Verantwortung zu übernehmen seine
Expertise einzubringen von Bafög digital
ich bin zuversichtlich dass die
Plattform spätestens Anfang
20022 freigeschaltet wird
unser Ziel am Ende des Winters da kommen
die heizkostenrechnungen da müssen die
200 Euro auf den Konten sein
meine Damen und Herren
bAföG-Empfänger erhalten zusätzlich mehr
Geld durch unsere bafög-reform und die
zwei Heizkostenzuschüsse wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass die Schulen warm bleiben
dass die Hochschulen ihre
Stromrechnungen bezahlen können weil uns
die jungen Menschen wichtig sind weil
wir wollen dass Sie wieder etwas
unbeschwerter leben können lernen können
ihre Talente entfalten können davon
profitieren wir übrigens alle ihre
Interessen sind unsere Interessen wir
vergessen das nicht
mit jeder Stille starke Watzinger die
Bundesministerin für Bildung und
Forschung zum Vorhaben der Koalition für
Studierende und Fachschülerinnen eine
energiepauschale zu zahlen über 200 Euro
und das Ganze im Laufe des nächsten
Jahres
diejenigen die in diesen Antrag stellen
dürfen müssen das Beantragen auf einer
digitalen Plattform die gibt's
allerdings noch nicht dann jeder Ludwig
aus der Unionsfraktion ist die erste
Rednerin aus der Opposition
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler 200 €
Energie pauschale bekommen sollen auf
den zweiten Blick erfriert einem
allerdings das Lächeln und die Freude im
Gesicht warum die Ankündigung ist vom
September wir haben jetzt November wir
haben jetzt die Rede der Ministerin
gehört und versuchen verzweifelt
zwischen den Zeilen zu hören werden nun
die Plattform auf der man diesen Antrag
stellen kann auf die 200 € eigentlich
erstellt verantwortet und betreibt Frau
Ministerin die Expertise von
Sachsen-Anhalt klingt gut aber die
Antwort ist es nicht wer macht's und wir
sagen ganz klar natürlich muss es der
Bund machen und es ist peinlich genug
dass sie nur mit einem Verweis auf die
Expertise von Sachsen-Anhalt sich hier
in die Debatte schleichen ganz ehrlich
und deswegen
wir wissen nicht wer es macht wir wissen
nicht wie es gemacht werden soll wie die
Antragstellung laufen sollte digital
nicht digital wir kriegen nur einen
holen Gesetzentwurf die Länder werden
nach ihrem eigenen Bekunden nicht
eingebunden sollen aber dann die
Verwaltungskosten tragen für ein
Instrument dass der Bund gerne
ausschütten möchte wir sagen alles
falsch sie haben seit September Zeit
gehabt dass sie haben seit September
Zeit gehabt das umzusetzen seit
September ist nichts passiert außer
Tiefschlaf im Ministerium und das ist
peinlich und deswegen noch mal peinlich
genug auch deswegen weil sie ja die
studierten ganz am Anfang sowieso
komplett vergessen hatten neben den
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern übrigens
deswegen es sind wir ganz klar die
Plattform muss der Bund machen und zwar
zügigst und dafür hatte er Zeit genug
die Verwaltungskosten muss ebenfalls der
Bund übernehmen und dann können wir
miteinander darüber reden ob das
Instrument funktioniert oder nicht
vielen herzlichen Dank
Daniela Ludwig aus der Unionsfraktion
geht alles nicht schnell genug im
September sagt sie sei die Pauschale
angekündigt worden aber immer noch nicht
da Lina Seidel aus der SPD-Fraktion mit
der Gegenrede
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren auf den Bühnen und Tribünen
und darüber hinaus ich denke wir sollten
uns noch mal klar machen um was es hier
geht es geht darum junge Menschen in
Ausbildung zu unterstützen und nicht
darum dass ich Bund und Länder und
Opposition und Regierung darüber
streiten wer wie wann was welches
verhaltensverfahren durchführt darum
geht es nicht es ist gut dass wir
außerplanmäßig mitten in den
haushaltswochen jetzt über diese
Einmalzahlung sprechen weil wir hier mit
die Rechtsgrundlage legen für die für
die entlastungszahlungen für rund 3
Millionen Studierenden fast einer halben
millionenfachschülerinnen und
fachschülern anspruchsberechtigt sind
also alle an einer deutschen Hochschule
immatrikulierten also auch Teilzeit
Studierende ausländische Studierende und
auch Promovierende wenn Sie in einem
promotionsstudiengang eingeschrieben
sind Anspruchs sind eben auch
Schülerinnen und Schüler in Fachschulen
und Berufsschulklassen also zum Beispiel
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher die derzeit
ihre schulische Ausbildung absolvieren
es ist richtig dass wir diese Entlastung
von 200 Euro jetzt machen warum das sind
Zielgruppen die infolge der stark
gestiegenen Energie- und
Lebensmittelpreise in besonderem Maße
von Armut bedroht sind wir haben bereits
viel verabschiedet wir haben zwei
bafög-novellen hier debattiert und
verabschiedet wir haben zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse für Bafög-Empfänger
in eröffnet wir haben die minijob-grenze
und den Mindestlohn erhöht wir haben das
49 Euro Ticket eingeführt was auch die
teureren Studie Tickets jetzt ersetzt
und wir haben ein bundländer Programm
junges wohnen aber und ich finde die
Studierenden fordern zu Recht
Einmalzahlung darlegen wir jetzt nach
und es ist eben auch wichtig dass diese
Einmalzahlung nicht nur an Studierende
geht sondern auch ein Ausbildungs-
ich möchte aber hier in dieser Debatte
nicht verhehlen dass wir uns als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion natürlich
gewünscht hätten dass dieses Gesetz
schon früher verabschiedet und die
Auszahlung bereits im Herbst gelaufen
wäre aber aber Frau Ludwig das Verfahren
ist eben nicht trivial wir haben eben
keine Liste aller Studierenden und erst
recht nicht aller Fachschülerinnen
Fachschüler mit eben mehr
trikulationsbescheinigung und Kontodaten
das haben wir nicht und das wissen sie
auch und es ist billig dass anders
einzufordern
und wir waren ja natürlich in den
letzten Wochen nicht untätig es ist viel
gesprochen worden es wurden im
Hintergrund Bund Länder Vereinbarung
bundländergespräche durchgeführt und
jetzt ist eine letztendliche
Entscheidung da es gibt eine und das
wiederhole ich noch mals müssen sie
eigentlich wissen es gibt eine
bundesweite digitale antragsplattform
die den Verwaltungsaufwand damit
deutlich reduzieren wird Gesetz
Geber haben wir jetzt alles
planen dass die Anspruchsberechtigten
noch in diesem Jahr den Antrag stellen
können und dass das Geld spätestens im
Januar auf deren Konto ist es ist unsere
klare Erwartung als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion dass die
Verwaltungsverfahren mit dem
parlamentarischen Verfahren jetzt
Schritt halten das heißt eine schnelle
Bereitstellung der Plattform und eine
schnelle Klärung der weiteren offenen
Fragen damit wir hier unbürokratisch und
schnell zu einer Auszahlung kommen wir
sind es nämlich den jungen Menschen
schuldig Ihnen zeitnah und
unbürokratisch diese versprochenen
Unterstützungszahlungen zukommen zu
lassen wichtig ist jetzt das Bund und
Länder hier zu einer schnellen
pragmatischen Lösung der Auszahlung
kommt die gesetzliche Grundlage haben
wir dafür jetzt gelegt vielen Dank
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort dr
Götz Frömming
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Frau Ministerin der polnische
Komponist Stefan Kirche Levski hat mal
gesagt der Sozialismus ist ein System in
dem man heroisch Probleme bekämpft die
andere Systeme gar nicht kennen wenn man
sich ihre Politik so anschaut dann
trifft das genauso zu meine Damen und
Herren heute Titel des Handelsblatt die
Stadtwerke verdoppeln ihre Preise für
Strom und Gas verdoppeln was sind die
Ursachen der Krieg in der Ukraine werden
Sie sagen höhere Beschaffungskosten das
erklärt es aber nur zum Teil
Verbraucherschützer und Ökonomen kommen
zu einem anderen Ergebnis es sind die
planwirtschaftlichen Eingriffe der
Bundesregierung die Strom und Gas teurer
machen als es sein müsste die sogenannte
Strom- und gaspreisbremse macht den
Wahrheit genau das Gegenteil von dem was
sie sollte die Preise werden nicht
gebremst sondern befeuert nun werden Sie
sagen ist ja egal denn die Kosten für
die Verbraucher die sind ja gedeckelt
auf 40 Cent bei Strom 12 Cent bei Gas
das gilt aber nur für 80% des Verbrauchs
und außerdem muss man doch fragen wer
zahlt denn den Rest dieses Deckels ist
das Herr Scholz Herr Lindner Herr Habeck
nein meine Damen und Herren das Zahlen
auch wieder die Verbraucher und die
Steuerzahler die hier die Dummen sind
das was Sie uns hier als soziale Politik
verkaufen wollen heute wieder ist in
Wahrheit das Gegenteil es ist asoziale
Politik meine Damen und Herren die
Profiteure sind Unternehmen und
Versorger in deren Aufsichtsrätin sie
sitzen nicht wir und jetzt also 200 Euro
als einmalige heizkostenschuh für alle
Studenten einige haben ja schon Zuschuss
bekommen die Minijobs haben meine Damen
und Herren was ist das für eine
erbärmliche flixschusterei wie weit soll
man denn damit kommen und wann kommt das
überhaupt noch nicht mal die
Online-Plattform steht wir haben es eben
gehört wenn Sachsen-Anhalt hier nicht
einspringen würde der Bund kann offenbar
nicht selbst mein Vorschlag lautet
verzichten Sie doch einfach mal auf den
trotzbau für Olaf Scholz 600 bis 900
Millionen Euro soll der Kosten dann
könnten wir sofort diesen Zuschlag
erhöhen von 3 und 300 Euro auf 500 Euro
das wäre doch mal was
aber letztlich geht natürlich das alles
an der eigentlichen Problematik vorbei
die Aufgabe einer wirklich
verantwortlich handelnden
Bundesregierung ist es doch nicht vor
Weihnachten nach Gutsherren Art Almosen
zu verteilen ihre Aufgabe wäre es für
bezahlbare Energie zu sorgen und unsere
Währung stabil zu halten dann wäre uns
allen gedient und genau daran werden wir
sie auch messen Frau Ministerin Liebe
Bundesregierung machen sie endlich ihre
Hausaufgaben es ist höchste Zeit vielen
Dank
und verbinden es 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Laura Kraft und Laura Kraft ist
Obfrau im Ausschuss für Bildung und
Forschung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren also da muss
ich ja direkt mal was sagen dass die
Union jetzt hier wieder aufmuckt und
hier rum meckert ja sie merkt sie
meckern ja gerade hier rum und haben
natürlich an allen was auszusetzen und
nur weil sie ständig ähm ja etwas
falsches erzählen und das immer
wiederholen da wird es da wird es davon
ja nicht wahrer denn sie behaupten ja
ständig bei jeder Debatte zu diesem
Thema das die dass die Koalition die
Studierenden vergessen hätte hat sie
nicht das stimmt de facto nicht wir
haben schon sehr schnell die
Studierenden mit in den Blick genommen
und ich habe das letzte Mal bei ihrem
Quatsch Antrag gemacht erinnern sie sich
an den noch und ich werde jetzt wieder
machen und wird Ihnen das noch mal
auflisten und helfen Ihnen jetzt noch
denken was wir jetzt schon alles gemacht
haben wo wir Studierende auch mit
entlasten nicht direkt aber die
entlasten Sie z.B auch indem wir die
bafög-sätze erhöht haben also die beiden
bafög-novel die wir auf dem Weg gebracht
haben das hat schon dafür gesorgt dass
schon zum Wintersemester mehr junge
Menschen vom Bafög profitieren können
anspruchsberechtigt sind und das auch
die bedarfsätze gestiegen sind wir haben
Kindergelderhöhung gemacht zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse Anhebung der
minijob-grenze
wegfall-eg-umlage und energiepauschale
verwerfstätige davon haben auch
Studierende je nach profitiert eine
wohngeldreform auf dem Weg gebracht und
es 9 € Ticket von den neuen euro-ticket
haben Studierenden auch profitiert und
jetzt kommt die Einmalzahlung die
wichtig ist die richtige ist die wir
jetzt in dieser Zeit brauchen denn ich
weiß wie schwer es gerade auch
Studierende haben ja es ist eine Gruppe
die müssen wir noch stärker entlassen
und es ist richtig dass wir für alle
Studierende das haben sie in der
Pandemie nämlich nicht geschafft dass
wir für dreieinhalb Millionen
Antragsberechtigte für diese Gruppe eine
Einmalzahlung auf dem Weg bringen und
jetzt auch umsetzen und dazu Gehör auch
internationale studieren dazu gehören
auch Promotions Studierende
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler das ist
alles mit drin das ist wichtig und es
ist auch richtig und wichtig dass das
ganze jetzt auch noch vor Weihnachten in
Kraft tritt also noch dieses Jahr denn
die Jahresabrechnung die kommt und da
muss das Geld nämlich vorher auf dem
Konto sein und das hat auch die Frau
Ministerin noch mal erklärt
es geht ja auch gar nicht ja
nein darum geht es überhaupt nicht es
geht letzten Endes darum dass wir in der
Breite entlasten und es geht ja auch gar
nicht nur um die Preise für Strom und
Gas dann müssen wir natürlich auch
weiter denken wir wissen ja nicht wie
sich die Krise noch verschärfen wird und
ich möchte einfach noch mal auf ein
Thema aufmerksam machen die
Lebensmittelpreise sind natürlich auch
gestiegen und mehr als 18 Prozent und
die Preise der Hochschule Mensen sind
auch um über 20% gestiegen und da müssen
wir auch schon dass wir da mehr machen
dass wir auch bei studentischen wohnen
noch mehr machen dass wir da noch das
nicht aus dem Blick verlieren aber ich
glaube jetzt mit dieser Einmalzahlung da
entlasten wir wirklich in der Breite da
helfen wir allen Studierenden wir haben
die Stimme fast weg
die Kollegin Salze hat das auch noch mal
erklärt wie es funktioniert und nur weil
sie das immer noch nicht verstanden
haben obwohl wir es auch im Ausschuss
schon tausendmal erklärt haben wie das
mit dem antragstool der letzten Endes
verlaufen wird und natürlich ist es auch
mit den Ländern abgesprochen dann kann
man ihn auch nicht weiterhelfen dann
müssen Sie einfach mal besser zuhören
oder vielleicht wollen sie es auch nicht
verstehen ich bin jedenfalls froh dass
diese Koalition diese Entlastung auf dem
Weg gebracht hat ich danke auch der
Ministerin und sie haben das auch noch
mal deutlich gemacht die Ampel wird die
Ampel ist dafür Studierenden hat
niemanden vergessen im Gegensatz zu ihm
in der Pandemie
machen wir uns ehrlich wer hätte das
gedacht dass es bei 200 Euro für
Studierende oder für Fachschülerinnen
[Musik]
so viel Emotionen geben kann im Plenum
gibt es aber ein lustiges hin und her
zwischen Koalition und Opposition
nächste Rednerin ist Petra Sitte
stellvertretender Vorsitzende der
Linksfraktion
die Energiepreise
e sind da heizungsstrom und
Lebensunterhalt haben ins Kontor
geschlagen die Inflation wird dieses
Jahr bei 8 bis 10% liegen bei einem
durchschnittlichen studentischen
Einkommen von ca 11.000 € pro Jahr sind
das nahezu tausend Euro 1000 €. junge
Menschen brauchen jetzt Hilfe sie
brauchen mehr Hilfe wir haben seit
Monaten dazu Vorschläge gemacht jetzt
werden langfristige Lösungen gebraucht
manche studierendenwerke haben die
Mieten in ihren Wohnheim um 60 € pro
Monat erhöht bzw mussten erhöhen 60 €,
da sind im Jahr schon mal allein 720 €,
also kommen Sie mir nicht mit den 200 €.
die Koalition schlägt also nun diese 200
€ vor diesmal für fast alle Azubis
bekommen erstmal nichts das wird
trotzdem nicht reichen viele junge
Menschen haben doch diese 200 € machen
wir uns da nichts vor längst ausgegeben
sie mussten sie ausgeben weil die
Stromrechnung durch die Decke gegangen
sind deshalb aber liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel es wäre gerade
jetzt so gut würden wir an dieser Stelle
endlich hören sie mir zu streiten sie
sich nicht das ist ja jetzt wichtig was
ich hier sage
gerade deshalb wäre es jetzt so gut wenn
wir über eine wirksame und grundlegende
bafög-reform reden würden und nicht über
Einmalzahlungen wir brauchen darüber
hinaus mehr studentischen Wohnraum wir
brauchen ihnen energieeffizient wir
brauchen ihn bezahlbar und die
studierendenwerke brauchen natürlich
Unterstützung damit sie ihre steigenden
Preise eben nicht an Studierende
weitergeben müssen meine Damen und
Herren es ist dennoch gut dass es auch
diese 200 € gibt dass es auch Fach und
Berufsschülerinnen bekommen aber bitte
jetzt geben sie endlich mal sage ich als
Radfahrerin Druck auf die Pedale damit
wir mit der technischen Umsetzung bald
über den Berg kommen danke
und der nächste Redner ist Stefan
Seidler
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin moin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als Vertreter
einer Grenzregion möchte ich auf ein
ganz konkretes Problem für die
grenzpanole Studierende aufmerksam
machen anders als grenzpendel der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
werden Studierende die einige Kilometer
über die europäische Grenze an ihre Uni
pendeln nach dem vorliegenden Entwurf
nicht von der energiepreispauschale
profitieren damit gehen Studierende zum
Beispiel über die deutsch-französische
Grenze an die Uni nach Straßburg pendeln
ebenso leer aus wie Studierende aus
Aachen die zur Uni nach Maastricht
fahren auch in meiner Heimat Region sind
zahlreiche Studierende betroffen die
über die Grenzen nach Dänemark pendeln
dies ist für eine Generation junger
Europäer die eigentlich keine Grenzen in
Europa mehr kennen sollten ein falsches
Signal unsere Grenzregion Leben von
einem aktiven Austausch und gerade
grenzpendelte junge Menschen verleihen
diesen Regionen und dem europäischen
Gedanken eine ganz besondere dy direkt
liebe ampelfraktion liebe Ministerin das
muss doch ein ungewollter Fehler von
ihnen sein bessern Sie bitte hier ganz
schnell nach
Stefan Seidler weil das vom
südschleswigchen wählerverband hat immer
nur sehr übersichtliche Redezeit und ist
natürlich auch fraktionslosen jetzt
kommt wir zu Oliver Katzen Marek aus der
SPD-Fraktion
Gesetz ist über das wir heute beraten
von dem profitieren insbesondere
Studierende aber auch Fachschülerinnen
und Fachschüler in dieser Situation mit
einem hohen Preisen wenn das schon das
fünfte Gesetz ist dann zeigt das doch
vor allem eins diese Koalition nimmt die
Lebenslage junger Menschen ernst wir
sind bereit nachzubessern und wir lassen
sie in dieser Zeit mit hohen Preisen
eben nicht alleine sondern nach prüfbar
auf dem Kontoauszug während sie
unterstützt
wollen einer Gruppe mit einem hohen
Armutsrisiko helfen mehr als ein Drittel
in aller Studierenden gelten als
armutsgefährdet und wir tun das auf
zweierlei Art und Weise das eine ist wir
schaffen einen Rechtsanspruch das heißt
wir verteilen keine Wohltat sondern wir
schaffen im Gesetzblatt einen Anspruch
auf Unterstützung für diejenigen die es
besonders schwer haben jetzt bei hohen
Energiekosten und zweitens ich verstehe
die Hinweise aus der Opposition zum
Verfahren nicht wenn man wir werden ein
sehr schlankes Verfahren keine
Kontoauszüge als armutsnachweise so wie
das in der Überbrückungshilfe in der
corona-pandemie beispielsweise noch der
Fall war sondern drei Schritte Online
Antrag stellen identitätsprüfungen im
Hintergrund dann kommt die Auszahlung
das ist effektiv das ist
rechtsverbindlich das ist wirksam das
kommt bei den Leuten am Ende auch
tatsächlich an
und ich möchte den Hinweis an der Stelle
auch noch mal aufgreifen den meine
Kollegin Lina Seidel schon gemacht hat
wir machen jetzt die gesetzliche
Grundlage in sehr hohen Tempo wir
stellen das Geld in dieser Woche mit dem
Haushalt bereit und die Erwartung an die
Bundesregierung ist tatsächlich dass wir
jetzt dazu kommen dass die Plattform
schnellstens an den Start geht und dass
wir Anfang des Jahres auch zur schnellen
Auszahlung an die Studierenden kommen
das muss unser ehrgeiziges Ziel sein das
ist unsere Erwartung
und die Einmalzahlung ist ja eingebettet
in mehrere Maßnahmen das ist ja hier
auch schon von mehreren Rednern
vorgetragen worden was wir machen die
zwei Heizkostenzuschüsse die wir
verabschiedet haben die einen
energiepreispauschale und an der Stelle
auch noch mal dahin heißt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
wenn ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender sich
gestern hier hinstellt und zum
wiederholten Mal wahrheitswidrig
behauptet die Studierenden sagen nicht
in der energiepreispauschale
berücksichtigt gewesen dann ist das ein
starkes Stück und ich gebe ihnen fragen
Sie doch einfach mal Studierende aus
ihren Wahlkreisen die haben nämlich wenn
Sie ein Arbeitsvertrag haben seit
September bereits die
energiepreispauschale überwiesen
bekommen und deshalb ich weiß nicht ob
Herr Merzig Bescheid weiß ob sie ihn
besser Briefen müssen dann ist das so
oder ob er das mit der Wahrheit nicht so
genau nimmt das kann ja auch sein sicher
ist aber dieser haltlose Unsinn darf
sich nicht weiter verbreiten er hilft
den Studierenden
und es ist vollkommen richtig dass du
das an der Stelle im Blick behalten was
wir jetzt kurzfristig tun müssen auch
bereit sein müssen nachzubessern aber
auch das im Blick behalten was zurecht
auch langfristig erforderlich ist wir
haben die bafögnovelle schon in Kraft
gesetzt wir wollen das mehr junge
Menschen im Bafög abgesichert ihre
Ausbildung machen können wir haben den
Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht das ist
für alle die Studierenden die auf eine
Nebentätigkeit angewiesen sind eine
substanzielle Lohnerhöhung gewesen der
die Union übrigens ihre Zustimmung
verweigert hat das sind Aufgaben die
langfristig vor uns liegen und deswegen
sage ich Heizkostenzuschuss eins und
zwei die Einmalzahlung
energiepreispauschale Bafög und jetzt
auch die mindestlohnerhöhung das sind
Maßnahmen die helfen und am Ende wird
sich das im Kontoauszug nachlesen lassen
und wenn wir noch mal helfen müssen dann
werden wir das auch noch mal tun
herzlichen Dank
Oliver katzmarek Sprecher für Bildung
und Forschung in der SPD-Fraktion hier
noch mal zum Studierenden bzw zur
Studierenden
energiepauschalle jetzt erregt man in
dieser Debatte bevor das der
Gesetzentwurf überwiesen wird in den
zuständigen Ausschuss des larsova aus
der Unionsfraktion
September verkündete die Bundesregierung
dass sie eine Einmalzahlung in Höhe von
200 € für Studenten und Studenten vorhat
es brauchte zwei weitere Monate bis die
Einmalzahlung vom Kabinett beschlossen
wurde und weitere zwei Monate bis sie in
Kraft tritt es werden aber weitere
Monate vergehen bis sie tatsächlich bei
den Studierenden ankommt weil sie haben
diese Plattform von der sie gerade
gesprochen haben diese digitale
Plattform noch nicht
und weil sie Frau Ministerin stark
Watzinger nicht wissen wie sie die
Studierenden und Schülerinnen und
Schüler der Berufsfachschule und
Fachschulen erreichen schieben Sie diese
Herausforderung jetzt an die Länder ab
mit ihrem Gesetzentwurf lassen Sie einen
leistungsgesetz mit einer
Verordnungsermächtigung zur späteren
Festlegung des konkreten Verfahrens zur
späteren Festlegung des konkreten
Verfahrens dieses Vorgehen ist völlig
planlos und entbehrt jeder föderalen
Zusammenarbeit
die Länder sind im Moment gerade damit
beschäftigt dafür zu sorgen dass ab
Mitte des Jahres die sprachkitas weiter
unterstützt werden weil auch diese
Aufgabe drücken Sie an die Länder ab sie
helfen den Ländern hier eine zusätzliche
Aufgabe über und statten sie in keinster
Weise ausreichend auf diese Aufgabe auch
zu bewältigen
und auch hier wird ihnen ihre
Untätigkeit in der Ampel wieder zum
Verhängnis ihr Koalitionsvertrag
formuliert einen umfassenden digitalen
Aufbruch bis auf die Formulierung einer
großen Digitalisierungsstrategie ist
bislang nichts geschehen wann gedenken
sie denn eigentlich nun mal aufzubrechen
denn sie wissen schon dass eine
Legislaturperiode vier Jahre hat oder
wenn Sie die von Ihnen angedachte
Plattformen zu beantragen
angebunden haben steht völlig in den
Sternen wann es zu einer Auszahlung
kommt wir haben gerade auch nochmal bei
den Kollegen in der FDP nachgefragt in
der corona-pandemie haben wir Zuschüsse
innerhalb von Wochen hinbekommen in
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern kleiner
Tipp die Förderbanken unserer Länder
sind dazu in der Lage sie müssen aber
mit den Ländern das gemeinsam besprechen
und die ich einfach sagen ihr macht das
jetzt wie viel wird in den wird den
Studierenden von dem Geld denn dann aber
bleiben bei einer Inflation von zehn
Prozent die wir aktuell haben 200 Euro
im September 2022 verkündet sind viel
viel weniger als 200 Euro im kommenden
Jahr
Studentinnen und Studenten gehören
bekanntlich zur Bevölkerungsgruppe die
erfahrungsgemäß nicht über ein üppiges
Geldvermögen verfügt sie brauchen das
Geld jetzt und deswegen bitte ich sie
nachdrücklich schnell zu handeln wir
haben hier akuten nach Rolle Bedarf
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
200 Euro sind zu wenig sagt Lars Rover
aus der Unionsfraktion
[Musik]
jetzt wird der Gesetzentwurf überwiesen
habe ich ihn schon gesagt Bildung und
Forschung der Ausschuss hat da die
Federführung